so what winning a trial because there's
no way and of course we'll ever and we
had a judge a guy that was a judge in my
defense thing he had been a judge and
his brother-in-law is in the New Orleans
Court of Appeals so you know we knew
that we would win okay I hired a Jean
Baker the Dean of the Harvard Law School
I had the best money could buy and uh
and we went I get convicted but the
funny thing is I get convicted but the
chapter believe in air force gets found
innocent and I'm like if that son of a
[ __ ] didn't sell anything what did i
buy what do you mean he's saying saying
I'm guilty yeah how does that work and
what happened was you know ego kills
people so I've always Wars what kills
people
ego ego your ego will kill you all the
time okay I always wore suit right I've
always dressed you know like like a
business person right well Alan Ross is
attorney who later on I would meet him
make him well it's just been our law
school he gets the guy's wife to go to
JCPenney and buy the cheapest clothes
and he has signs with her because she do
speak English right so whenever he went
like that she was kind of that so he
ain't and he and here the guys looking
like a beggar now I walk into the
courtroom with bodyguards in a limo
dressed like freakin John Gotti or
something right with my ex-wife who was
a beauty queen and that judge looks at
me so he only has one attorney I have
five in my table and the judge looks at
me says mr. Valdez how can you tell this
court you're innocent you got a million
dollar with the lawyers
everyone knows a young man cannot afford
that I mean it was like crazy and so I
get convicted I'm giving the high
sentence 15 years 15 years pleasure
parole $250,000 fine and I go off to
prison to win to wait for my appeal and
I had a blast in prison in a blast yeah
I saw you guys say he had a hard time
when you're nobody you have a hard time
but if you got money in prison I went
there and a lot of people work for me or
someone to work for me so I mean I
I have brand-new sheets every day I
think I know where the sheets that he
lays watch him I went to Tallahassee
which at that time was one of the most
dangerous President America they called
gladiator school because in Tallahassee
in in Washington DC every crime is a
federal crime so what happens is anybody
coming whereas the federal inmate during
that period of time was more of a
white-collar smuggler you know yeah
people that were not violent right well
in DC you had all those murderers
rapists ha and they all went to
Tallahassee so every week I was a state
prison now fed it was a federal but in
DC every crime is a federal crime right
because it's a Commonwealth okay so
every week it was for dorms 150 men like
a barracks like a military barracks and
every week they would search and they
have this drum 55-gallon drum full
shanks all kinds of our weapons all
kinds of homemade knives and stuff like
that and I was just 23 but everyone knew
I had more money than anybody else yeah
I bought every guard that I could you
know and whenever they brought meat for
beef stew I would buy all the meat I had
I'm the only I made that I went to eat
and I had a tablecloth on my table so I
live like a king because I also in
exchange I kept the peace in the prison
then I get transferred
well I bribe because I could have never
gone transferred to Eglin Air Force Base
which was a camp right at that time they
called it fed camp that's like a
free-for-all camp yeah yeah I mean bars
is they draw a red line on the ground in
across that but we go out and you work
in the military base you know Eglin is
the largest Air Force Base in the world
so you go work there and you're driving
a truck you're like a free man so when I
went to Eglin well what happened was one
of my attorney became very good friends
with the designating officer in Atlanta
who designated image because I was never
she had never been designated to eggman
right because I was a very high profile
I was what they call residual
jurisdiction which means you had over a
big family and all the cases go to
Washington but this guy was about to
retire
and I gave him $50,000 to
just like made me directly so I guess in
fact that man I walked into a prison
right straight to the captain's office
the words often I don't know how the
[ __ ] you got here you don't belong here
I don't know who you paid off I'm like
Warren you mean that federal employees
take bribes I didn't know that he like
get out of here but I'm watching you and
don't ever think that you're gonna walk
work in that base I said sir I'm just
here to do my time I got three years
left I'm not causing no problem I don't
have a single write-up in the prison I
got a great you know resume Jews through
my time so they assign me to a dental
office and the hospital which is the
best job there I'm Wars white suit and I
ended up having a relationship with one
of the females that worked in the
hospital for about a year and a half and
then they thought that something was
going on on a Friday so on a Friday we
had dental office locked up cleaning all
the instrument and the associate warden
comes and when the door was like top
he's like what the hell is going on here
I'm like we got like that because the
system and you don't want the image to
have access to the instrument and you
know that person can say yeah well he
was just cleaning up and you're
supervising him and he's like couldn't
say nothing and next Saturday night when
all just something that when the Java
Simon's come out people come to my bunk
and they're like dude you're out of
there I'm like what yeah they assigned
you to the base I'm like yeah send me to
the base oh man that's my punishment
usually is that the worries that they
think that you you had something going
out with one of the female workers right
I'm like all right so I go to the base
and then after a week you know I'm a
sign of crew so I go up to the guy
running the crew and I said look I'll
make a deal with you I'll give you 500
hours a week you pick us up in the
morning sign us out give me the truck
I'll take the crew I'll surprise him but
leave me alone you go he had a
girlfriend good good go see your
girlfriend yeah
how are you crazy I'll be damned if I'm
early
he was a bit already neck if I'm gonna
let some speak go ahead and tell me what
to doesn't I said I'm just suggesting
that I can do this and you can have fun
and you can make some money so on Friday
I disappeared all the equipment out this
big old military truck that we drove all
the lawn mowers and weed eaters and so
so he checks us out he goes to check his
back into a prison and as I'm about to
go in he comes running Valdez now
there's about this and I'm like was the
problem
he said you son of a [ __ ] where's my
equipments in the back of the truck we
just left it a couple of minutes ago I
said as my crew yeah six of them I said
come here guys well I'm the dryer I'm
the driver by the way so I don't look in
the back well you guys put the littoral
you know seven thousand out towards
three of them and they're like in the
back of the truck man he was just about
to cry said look I'll make you a deal
you take my original deal and I'll I'm
gonna run the prints off find out what
the hell happened to you equipment and
if I can find it for you Monday morning
I'll give you the money how much is it
13:38 some $1,000 I said I'll give you
the money
okay okay please please please this is
my whole retirement this is my second
job I retired from the military three
years ago all right no problem
we had hidden it on the beach and I'm
like oh we can I'm like I hope nobody
runs into this freak I will lay out $38
for this freaking joke we come back and
the money was there I mean the equipment
was there and he let me do whatever and
I meet a girl they came through is her
father who later on I got married to her
and I used to leave the base every day I
used to laugh I say I said if a prison
inmate goes out of this big secure Air
Force Base what the hell are the
Russians doing and I bought an apartment
right outside of Eglin and I went home
every day I went home every day I I
ain't good
I had sex for how many for two and a
half years for two and a half years and
at the end there was this lieutenant was
a friend of mine he was really really
cool and so I'm walking like the fine
release men did all my time and as I'm
walking out he says to me
please tell me the truth what are you
seeing your wife I said I was and he's
like where we would spend all day long
looking through this entire freaking
base I said you look in the wrong place
I was outside the base he said you know
how the boss did you I said yeah I did
said I left everything
[Laughter]